la situation se dégrade mais n'est pas
encore catastrophique pour la première
fois depuis début décembre le nombre de
patients atteints par le cos vide 19
admis en réanimation a dépassé les 3200
un chiffre élevé mais loin d'être au
niveau des pics des 1er et 2nd
confinement en avril dernier plus de
sept mille malades avaient été admis
contre eux près de 5000 mi novembre
par ailleurs les hôpitaux ne sont pas
saturés alors qu'il l'avait été au
printemps dernier 136 % des lits de
réanimation étaient occupés le 8 avril
90 % au mois de novembre et 63% à
l'heure actuelle le nombre de cas de
kovy 19le semble quant à lui se
maintenir en moyenne entre le 23 et le
29 janvier
vingt mille personnes auraient été
contaminées chaque jour en france soit
une augmentation de 1% par rapport à la
semaine précédente
des chiffres qui permettent encore aux
gouvernements d'estimer la situation
sous contrôle
la question d'un confinement se pose
légitimement compte tenu de ces données
mais nous en connaissons l'impact très
lourd pour les français sur tous les
plans
ce soir nous considérons au regard des
chiffres des derniers jours que nous
pouvons encore nous donner une chance de
l'éviter
pour autant un facteur bouscule les
comparaisons avec 2020 l'arrivée des
variants du coc vie 19 et notamment le
varia anglais estimé bien plus
transmissible comme le montrent les taux
de positivité le variant anglais va
prendre le dessus
on a les premiers résultats en région
parisienne qui ne sont pas bons on était
à 6 % le 7 janvier on est monté à 15 ou
20 pour cent la semaine dernière
et comme le varia anglais et 40 à 70%
plus contagieux
il va y avoir une accélération de
l'épidémie si on ne fait
significativement rien de plus c'est ça
qui nous fait peur des résultats qui
pourraient bien peser dans la balance
les prochains jours vont donc être
déterminant le gouvernement devrait être
très attentif aux contaminations
quotidienne
et si elle venait à exploser comme
c'était le cas juste avant le second
confinement avec une augmentation de
2000 cas chaque jour un troisième
confinement pourrait se confirmer